Words I have learned in the Dominican Republic and their meaning in Spain.
Motoconche is 1 motorcycle which is 1 cab in which 2 or more
people go without a helmet and if you are walking down the
street most likely they will and ask you if you want to get on.
1 that I love is the name of the badenes that is
policeman lying down because it makes you brake like 1
policeman and as he is on the ground is as if he were lying down.
The lighter is the sparkle,
the oven and the place where it cooks is the stove what in
Spain is the fan here is the fan Scooter type motorcycles
are the passalas the cars the cars the cars the quads for
Wills and the biggest cars that are like 1 go here are the buses.
Minced meat is ground meat which in Spain is called libreta here
is called mascota Bags are called holster because here bag means
something else If I have said a bad word or you want to add others,
let me know.